being watched
hey mom
yeah Johanna still has a fever and it's
been like three days the doctorate
mm-hmm yeah we can't go to the doctor
mom we can't afford it he doesn't have
insurance I think he only has this one
from Austria I gave him like everything
in the medicine cabinet already like I
don't even know if it's okay with what I
gave him well can't you ask uncle Eric
if he can write a prescription for a
z-pack or anything yeah I know it's late
okay yeah awesome yeah well all right
love you
thank Megan oh it's a dream yes was the
dream and I can't believe you're
dreaming about your ex you're so lucky
you're sick right now otherwise I would
kill you I'm gonna stay in her no [ __ ]
yes I forget about it my mom says she's
living in my uncle to write your
prescription and you just need to stay
hydrated and get Pony arrest
you hear that I don't hear anything
babe you just need to relax it's a fever
just take a couple of these
no I mean yeah calm down crazy well
check it out
it's scaring me
hello
[Music]
anyone there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sweet dreams
[Music]
[Music]